[Music]
appends no radio no newspapers a
political conversation visitors a once
per month I could get used to this
whether white Mandela you know the most
deluded of them all we've heard about
you dude
how many of family plan on staying that
long it's evolved wire service
everything and she taught boys with guns
locked up into porn panels in any
direction they just lead you back on the
prison property yeah everybody comes in
here and I'm gonna break out of here
Bonnie exclaiming always the first time
it's much exactly one lengthy with
answers Android no that's crazy
so all we have to do is make a really
complete escape then get it to reach a
keyhole on the other side of a steel
panel greens they can told to which we
have totally no access I love it
if I'll get 25 years of your lucky a
bullet in their head of you not
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
your whole plan is doomed to failure
didn't do anything we are prisoners of
conscience it's different for us well
we're prisoners of war
[Music]
that is how much ever it strike us
this is how we find
hold on to the angle then imagine is
another won't but suppleness
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]